this is a production of cornell
university
uh i am going to walk you through a few
different things today i'm going to talk
about the grow new york program
i believe i am now sharing the
presentation that i put together for
this
um the program's origin
how it operates what the competition is
i'm going to take a closer look at three
of our winners that are uh
horticulture adjacent and then i'm going
to
additionally talk about a research
initiative that we took on
this year to add some complexity to the
program
um it's co-produced with the center of
excellence for food and agriculture at
cornell agritech
and it's a ground-up report on what the
common constraints
are felt by growers and producers here
in new york state
of high commodity or emerging
um crops so um
first what is grow new york uh grow new
york
is a program that is built around a
business competition
that's intended to attract innovation
at all points in the agri-food system to
our region so everything from
very far upstream farm operations
technologies down to a consumer packaged
good
like a granola bar that you would walk
into a supermarket and pull off of
a shelf uh it's global
in that we're trying to attract
companies from all over the world
um but it's centered right here uh in in
our
in our region and uh i am the program
director
i work for cornell's center for regional
economic advancement
cornell executes this program with
funding that we receive through
empire state development um greg
mentioned it's a million-dollar
top prize it's actually three million
dollars of prizes a year
so one million dollar prize to 500 000
prizes and uh for 250 000
prizes and what that does is it allows
us to work with
uh companies that are at various stages
of development so
um a startup might not really be in a
position
to effectively spend a million dollars
in such a way that they're going to be
able to see
economic impact results uh in a 12-month
period which is the
the period against which we um form an
agreement
uh so this lets us work with some
earlier companies at that
500 and 250 000 um
levels so i i've mentioned our region
the the grow new york region is uh
from just west of rochester to just east
of syracuse from lake ontario down to
the pennsylvania border
that region is comprised of three of the
state's 13
regional economic development committee
regions the finger lakes central new
york and the southern tier
rochester being the kind of capital city
of the finger lakes syracuse of central
new york
and depending on who you ask ithaca or
binghamton for the southern tier
so uh this region
uh self-selected in that the funding for
the prize money
is from upstate revitalization
initiative
funding that new york state gave to each
of these regions
this grow new york is the only
initiative
that is being funded by
multiple redc regions so it's the three
regions that agreed to collaborate on
this project
each put in kitty for that prize money
for a three year period
um and uh
i'm actually going to stay there for one
moment uh
the the reason for this region being the
target area besides
the the simple fact that that's where
the funding is coming from
is has to do with the tradition of
agriculture
and the strength in food production and
distribution
that we see in this area so the grow new
york region is cumulatively home to the
largest numbers of jobs in the food and
ag sector
in new york state 44 of the state's
farms
are in this region
the top 10 new york state counties in
terms of farmland as share of total farm
area is in this region
when you rank counties by farm sales the
top
five are in the grow new york region
there are over 260 food and bev
manufacturers there are more than 16 000
farms and ag-based businesses and there
are
more than 112 000 manufacturing jobs in
the region which also plays into this
we also have a really brilliant
ecosystem
for small business incubation in this
region so
there are a number of um important
hubs for entrepreneurial support
and and uh nurturance incubator works
which is in corning
binghamton has the startup suite which
deals with spin-offs from binghamton
university
there's a clean energy incubator in
uh in binghamton the kaufman southern
tier clean energy incubator
here in ithaca we have uh rev ithaca
startup works which is a sector agnostic
incubator uh on campus we have praxis
which is
high tech spin-offs we have the mcgovern
center
which is life science spin-offs out in
geneva
we have the cornell food and ag
technology park
we have the center of excellence which
i've already mentioned which includes
the food venture center
in syracuse there's the tech garden
which is a sector agnostic
incubator but which also runs genius
which is a program
specifically for uh unpersoned aerial
vehicles so
drones and then in rochester there's
nexcor which is similarly
sector agnostic they support
entrepreneurs of any kind
but they run the luminate program
which is for optics photonics and
imaging
so there is this really incredible and
diverse
deep support that's available to people
that want to start businesses
up in the region within cornell i
mentioned
practices in mcgovern we work closely
with
the johnson school with agritech and
throughout cals
we also work with the center for digital
ag
and cornell atkinson but also within
this region
are several other research institutions
that play a role in the grow new york
program
rochester institute of technology
lemoine
hobart william smith syracuse suny esf
suny morrisville and binghamton all play
a role
in helping us help startups that are
working in the food and ag space plug
into the region and understand
uh why it makes sense for them to locate
their businesses here
we also have a really extensive partner
group so
this is a slide that we use during the
summit
that we hold which i'll say more about
in a moment but
these represent our partners kind of my
closest advisors
on the program and what these partners
uh
do besides guide and and
help shape the program is offer
advice networking um
and just a variety of different kinds of
consideration to the startups that we
work with in the grow new york program
so
you get somebody who's working on um
you know a technology that involves food
packaging
it only makes sense to to work with
wegmans to see if you can
kind of pilot that in some of their
stores or
uh you're looking for space to
open your lab well it makes sense to
talk to one of the ida's
or the chambers of commerce that are
going to have ideas about
um attractive places both in terms of
your
production needs and in terms of
economic favorability so it's a
pretty impressive and also expansive
group of different kinds of companies
that are
involved and they're deeply involved in
shaping the program
with me so uh
who can compete in the grow new york
competition
i mentioned that it's food and ag the
entire agri-food system
end-to-end um in order to
apply you need to be
a real company right you need to have
registered yourself and you need to be
an llc or a corporate entity
so uh not-for-profits um
or other kinds of entities aren't able
to apply
the primary reason for that is the prize
money that million dollar top prize the
smaller prizes
that's all structured as an investment
that cornell university is making into
the startup
and so um we need to be able to get into
that kind of agreement
we're looking for companies that have a
real potential for hockey stick
kind of growth so um greg mentioned
my past is working with a lot of smaller
producers farms that are looking to add
value to to their land through things
like craft beverage
um smaller hospitality ventures those
are all really
important parts of the uh you know the
economic health
of our region but this particular
program
is for companies that can scale up
quickly where land constraints
uh production constraints aren't really
an issue that as long as
there's the uh the resources to grow
there's the capability to grow
uh at a at a fast rate we're also
looking for for really genuinely unique
uh products and and innovations and
we're looking for those companies to be
early stage
and what we mean about early stage is
we we have here four different criteria
you have to
meet at least two of them right so
you're not
decades old um but you
are actually out there with more than
just an idea or a science experiment you
actually have a product
that you can move along with your early
revenue maybe you've raised some friends
and
family investment or seed funding
and you have a leadership team in place
that can
that can really move you rapidly towards
growth
uh the the applications are judged
two times there's an initial uh judging
that that
that takes us from the total application
submit submitted last year we received
264 applications and we take that down
to
a group of 20 finalists that we put
through a business development stage
and the criteria that we use uh
in that initial screening has to do with
viability which is to say
what's your business model how are you
going to generate revenue
what is the cost structure that you're
looking at how do we
know that you're ready to fulfill on the
proposition that that you're offering
team
which is a demonstration of a level of
cohesion and completeness and readiness
and
also this is something that we've
articulated a little more
a little more clearly and emphatically
this year that
your team reflects diversity and
inclusion amongst its founders employees
and advisors
to allow you to deliver on your
potential and when you're applying you
have both the opportunity to talk about
the diversity
that is currently part of your team but
also to talk about
how in the next 12 to 18 months you're
going to extend that diversity and
increase the inclusion within your
company
customer value do people want to buy
what you're selling
um is there a market for your product
agriculture and food innovation so how
are you pushing the state the state of
the art what is
new um and how does
your idea or your product or your
service
uh contribute to making upstate new york
a leader
in food and ag innovation and then
finally the regional job creation piece
so
what uh what can you do in terms of
creating opportunity direct
within your company and indirect um
and how uh how is your
business relevant to the existing food
and ag
ecosystem that we have here
so uh there isn't a residency
requirement
for grow new york um we are
looking for you to operate in the region
and that can be
fairly indirect we don't care where you
get your
mail delivered you don't have to have a
headquarters here
you may want to have for example a lab
an r d
facility a manufacturing facility or you
may be partnering extensively with
someone
a co-packer a manufacturing
facility um that you're making
substantial capital investments that
kind of lift the tide overall here in
the region
there we go so uh
we are i mentioned that we screened down
to a cohort of 20 finalists
those finalists are put through a
business development phase that consists
of about two and a half months
they get identified in september get
assigned a mentor who's a member of the
regional or someone from within the
finger lake central new york or the
southern tier who have expertise
in entrepreneurship um
usually some knowledge either of food
production
or of agriculture and are real um
connectors right they're the kinds of
people that that want to introduce you
to everyone they know and so that's what
their job is
uh during the business development phase
startups work with the mentors
to identify the resources in the region
and those are
primarily people who can help answer
questions about
how their technology their innovations
can best
fit in the region and in doing so
estimate what the regional
impact can be and then that estimation
is part of the live pitch that these
startups
make at our grow new york summit so
the uh the same criteria
that we use to select down to that group
of 20 finalists
is applied by a group of seven judges
who are a vip panel who hear a live
pitch
and engage in about 10 minutes of q a
with the startups
uh and and then the seven winners are
identified
our first year this was all live last
year was all virtual this year we're
going to do a hybrid what exactly that
will look like is to be determined
i'm hopeful and and uh and i think it's
a realistic hope that we'll be able to
convene
the competitors and the judges at
minimum and
so have that pitch actually be live and
in person
which will be a lot of fun it's it's
really dynamic when when you can see the
startups
answering those questions in real time
the summit itself is going to occur
in syracuse this year again you know
barring
uh some unexpected backslide it seems
like we should
at least be able to get the participants
and by that i mean
the um the the teams the 20 teams that
are competing the judges the mentors
and then any panelists and speakers that
we have
together in syracuse so the summit
consists of
the live pitch but also um you know
a series of panels and presentations
that address
issues that are relevant to our region
in the food and egg space um
and uh just to give you a quick overview
of the timeline and i am hoping that
some of you
have uh technologies and companies that
you're you're thinking about
spinning off and and are considering
whether to apply
the applications open in uh just a
couple of days on wednesday
they close in mid-july the finalists
will be announced in september so that
first round of screening that i
mentioned
occurs between july 15th and early
september
and uh the mentoring and the business
development trip uh
which if we're able to to host to these
teams in the region we will do so we did
that in year one
that occurs in september october and the
summit
itself the pitch competition and the
symposium
will be november 16th and 17th
so a quick look at the winners that
we've seen thus far
they represent a great deal of diversity
uh in terms of where they sit in the
agri-food system
our top prize winner in year one was a
company out of geneva
called real eats it's a meal
subscription service
and they were poised for tremendous
growth even before
kovid put everyone at home ordering
their food
online they've had really remarkable
growth
uh they closed on a 2.5 million dollar
seed round uh last summer they
uh excuse me series a round last summer
they had 183 growth in terms
of uh revenue year over year so
they're really um on a tear their
the commitment that they made within the
agreement with us
in terms of their milestones and what
they needed to deliver to receive their
prize money
was adding 10 jobs uh in their 12-month
period
in fact in that year they added 43 jobs
so they've just been a really wonderful
uh startup to partner with in our first
year we've been able to demonstrate a
lot of value
the two 500 thousand dollar winners one
is drop copter i'm going to talk
a little more extensively about them in
a minute um the other is a company
called tiliter
and they're based in australia they were
our first international winner
they are working on ai technology that
effectively
lets you scan at the supermarket
checkout
so you don't have to have a sticker that
lets you know that it's a fuji and not a
gala
apple right the the ai technology can
just
see and assess that so eliminating the
resources of you know time and material
um and nobody likes stickers on their
fruit right
so that's that's their technology
um the four 250 thousand dollar prize
winners are great examples of
early companies that have a great deal
of potential and
and needed you know this kind of cash
influx has been
a really um important part to them
standing up um capro x upcycles dairy
waste specifically from the greek yogurt
production so
the acid way that's a byproduct of of
greek yogurt
they upcycle that into biofuels
and bioplastics um and they have
partnered with
burn dairy for a pilot and since winning
have opened up a lab and hired a couple
of folks
complex i'm going to go into in a little
more depth uh the perfect granola
is a granola company that has a very
uh well articulated discrete social
mission
um they recently uh as of just last week
uh partnered with pepsico so they're uh
you know able to really expand their
kind of one
for one when there's a purchase then
there's a donation
approach to getting food into uh new
york city schools
and then whole healthy food which is a
functional ingredient company that
develops
has developed an extraction process to
get particular kinds of proteins
out of in this case white kidney beans
but they'll they're looking forward to
expanding
on their product offerings in the future
year two the top prize winner
is a company out of israel called soos
they mitigate
male kick chick culling uh using
sound engineering to transform
male eggs into egg-laying females
it's pretty remarkable technology and
it's a reasonable question to say but
jen there's no substantial poultry
industry in the grow new york region
why them in fact it's the uh it's the
sound
engineers that they're looking for and
that
research ecosystem that i was talking
about the the various
uh schools in the region have the kind
of
workforce um prospects that stuce is
working for
so it's a real great fit and it looks
like they're going to locate their
facility
right outside of rochester so fresh has
a packaging material
that extends the shelf life of fresh
bread but will also be applicable to
things like
small berries zetify
is a piece of hardware that helps expand
broadband reach and reliable
connectivity
that has great applications for farmland
in upstate new york
and then uh of the four 250 000 prize
winners
candidates i'm going to talk about in a
little more depth
hallamine is a company that develops
antimicrobial products
uh that are used in the food supply
system
leap foods is a mushroom company
that grows on a recycled hardwood
substrate
they're also getting into rather than
selling mushrooms direct to consumers
selling mushrooms as ingredients to
um better for you meat producers so
you know kind of ex cutting meat with
mushrooms
and then pure space is a company out of
south korea that also has
um a shelf life extension
product there's uh specifically
addresses ethylene gas
so again firm operations consumer
packaged goods everything
in between uh in the two years that
we've been operating we're now launching
our third year
we've seen some really substantial
uh opportunity creation that's clearly
part of what we're looking for in teams
their ability to fulfill on that
they've done so so um more than 50
direct jobs hundreds of indirect jobs
a number of commercial leases signed and
especially through the work that real
eats is doing with local
food producers and growers hunt more
than 100 agreements
with producers and suppliers
we're seeing innovation across a variety
of different
sectors in the agri-food system we're
seeing international recognition of the
program which is great but also it means
the region is getting a reputation
internationally as a place where
exciting things in agriculture and food
production are happening
we've had coverage in more than 15
companies in the countries that that
that um is represents six six
uh continents and we're seeing the teams
that we've selected
grow um fulfill on their
on their agreements with us but also go
on to
have a really impressive follow on
funding
both from venture capital and from other
sources
in particular the national science
foundation sbir
grants we've had a couple of winners
land really substantial
sbir grants and then um other funding
usda grants etc non-dilutive um
funding sources so 13 million dollars
um you know our year two winners were
only
uh identified last november so
you know we're fewer than six months and
i would say that a
full third of that funding has has come
through
through those teams so um the program is
really working
to create a sense of
of their here and to help these
companies
grow to their full potential i mentioned
looking at a couple of the companies
more closely so drop copter
it's aerial pollination um
and uh you know part of the reason i'm
going a little more in depth on these
three is i invite you
to think about your research um and how
it could be commercialized and how
you could stand up a company and
and maybe uh join in the competition in
coming years we
hope to be renewed for another three
years initially so
it's envisioned as a 12-year program
overall
um so uh bees
are declining expensive um
what can drones do these the drop copter
uses drones to pollinate presently
almonds apples dates
um they're looking forward to other nut
and seed crops and and other
fruit in the future um what is
interesting to me is uh they started off
uh the the drone expertise came far
before any kind of
uh experience working in ag the uh
the initial inventor the founder of the
company
first wanted to have a drone delivery
system so you could get food
and drinks out to folks on golf courses
so
it would sort of bring it to to you at
whatever
uh whatever hole you're at and there
were a variety
of issues with that and he you know
learning as he had gone to
to come to syracuse to do the genius
program i mentioned which is
specifically for unpersoned aerial
vehicles
and in being in syracuse kind of got
some awareness of you know
agriculture in general and particularly
the um
the apple industry and so uh
kind of piloted the uh drone pollination
technology in wayne county um
their treatments increase crop yields
considerably they estimate between 10
and 60
um their precision fight paths guarantee
that uh pollination occurs
more cohesively and nighttime operation
can double
the uh the bloom window of trees
so uh they came as i said to syracuse in
october of 2017
as part of the genius program they went
into residency at the tech garden
in winter 2018. they competed with us in
november 2019
and as of october 2020 they partnered
with
um uh blue white robotics
which is an israeli company that has
opened um
a branch office here in upstate new york
in central new york
um they are looking to offer an autonomy
platform for drones and other kind of
robotic
uh machinery that integrates
uh multiple types of robots and will
they they their pitch is that it's
like amazon web services but for
uh but for mechanical equipment for
farms so
um non-technical users can
access um the the management console
to manage their fleet of drones or the
drones that they're say
using that that belong to drop copter so
that that partnership's been really
productive for drop copter
the second team i'm going to talk about
is complex um they're coming
out of um out of cornell
uh they were
originally uh thinking about
a a an internet of things for beekeepers
so um how
can they um
how can they help uh beekeepers
manage performance by collecting and
analyzing
the data of their hives and it turns out
that beekeepers didn't really want that
and that
that theme of um
solutions in search of problems is
something i'll come to with the the
when i talk about the report that we've
put together but
what what what they realized was
there there was a substantial problem
varroa mites
that they could address
uh and come up with a really
high impact company that would uh help
overall bee health and um
and so they developed this uh
laser technology that zaps varroa
mites off of the backs of bees without
hurting the bees the bees don't love it
but it doesn't
it doesn't kill them they are still um
able to to go in and out of the hive and
and on their way
um so they developed this idea
starting in spring 2018 and they entered
the i-corps program which is the
national science foundation's innovation
corps
korea the center for regional economic
advancement that i work with um that's
my organization
we run the i-corps program for cornell
um
it helps uh inventors faculty students
ideate how to commercialize their
product effectively
um they jumped into tech stars in spring
2019
they won 250 000 from us at new york in
2019
after that they received an nsf sbir
grant um they went on
to win the 76 west clean energy
competition in 2020
taking home uh another 500
000 and and now they're in rev
it's like a startup works prototype to
production
um program and haley who's one of the
founders
uh noted that the grow new york funding
allowed them to
work with a couple of different contract
engineers to turn the lab bench project
into a real minimum minimally viable
product
um that they took the sbir grant and are
able to
optimize the optical system the lasers
um for fda approval and with the 76 when
west they're growing their team and
their apiaries to
work towards their overall growth using
honeybee tech to
incentivize sustainable ag and
pollinator-friendly practices across the
united states so
really excited about the work that
they're doing
um and then this year candidates was one
of our 250
000 winners um candidates
is a company that offers supplemental
lighting
for the um the cea
sector um their
product consists of responsive lighting
hardware which you see on the left
a controller system which is software
and then a data analytics
service and they're very early
they're they're a very early stage
company um
effectively what they offer is
technology
that can say the sun is shining
we don't need to turn the lights on it's
a little cloudy
let's turn the lights on a little it's
very dark let's turn those lights way up
and uh the growers can determine the
the light requirements and candidates
controls the hardware so that it
meets those lights light requirements
with the kind of minimum
um use of of electricity
uh and so it offers precise
lighting with the uh greatest efficiency
possible and um
and interestingly the uh
the one of the founders is the director
of the greenhouse
lighting and systems engineer uh
blaze consortium of which cornell
is a part so um very excited to see how
they grow
they uh are moving their operations up
here they've chosen to relocate
entirely from georgia up here to the
grow new york region
uh the last thing that i want to talk
with you about
is as i said a report that we're working
on
uh within my organization it started off
as
um as a an initiative for the grow new
york region but in partnering with the
center of excellence we decided to
expand the scope and be
new york statewide so that it supported
the center of excellence's
statewide mandate and our feeling was
that by and large
uh where goes the grow new york region
so goes uh the rest of the state in
terms of food production and agriculture
there's some outliers there obviously we
don't
have a robust fishing aquaculture
sector here but other than that it's a
it's it's pretty relevant
to to to grow new york so we wanted
to offer something that was an overview
of uh of our agri-food system in the
region
that touches on venture capital trade
trends
themes for innovation and also reflects
the voice of the farmer
so that we can kind of play it out to
inventors and investors nationwide to
say
anybody's welcome to apply for the grow
new york program but if you're working
in these kinds of technologies or you're
interested in investing in these kinds
of technologies
look here first we have some pretty
amazing resources to offer you including
a million dollar
top prize um so the
report identifies the themes of
innovation that could
mitigate transform and solve the central
issues that are felt by growers here
and we're really hoping that it draws in
relevant technologies
and investment to address those themes i
already talked about the scope of it but
just
to note a little further it does include
some emerging crops particularly hemp
which is um you know not
one of our top commodities
um today but we see a lot of potential
there
otherwise it's the top commodities
according to national ranking
um so we looked at the most
frequently cited issues by farmers
which you know these were the issues
that were repeatedly brought up in a
series of over a hundred individual
interviews
um boils down to concerns about rising
production expenses downward pressure on
prices from retailers
and manufacturers um we did see some
optimism
around uh from from diversified produce
farmers with direct to consumer retail
channels
um we saw some growth in organic
production
uh and uh
most of the diversified vegetable and
fruit growers including apple growers
were expanding their organic
operations largely due to the premium
they felt they could command
in the marketplace for those products so
rising labor costs
uh were the single largest issue
that that uh the most most frequently
cited issue
um so it's pushing interest in
mechanization and robotics
particularly for large farms and
manufacturing facilities
there are some cost concerns for smaller
farms they worry they'll get lost behind
as they struggle to
afford new equipment and technology and
uh they cited issues farmers that is
cited issues like
lack of mechanized options for
high-value crops and varied ripening
times currently
relying on a human eye and judgment so
these are
areas that we think technologies
would be really well well suited in the
region
climate change remains
an issue uh most farmers pointed to an
increase in weather volatility
injecting uncertainty into the growing
season over the past decade more heavy
rains
posing threats to planting and crop
yields wetter warmer winters
increasing disease and pest pressure
soil erosion late spring frosts
increasing disease and pest pressure so
there's
a sense of evolution about what they
anticipate
being able to grow and there'll be a
need for innovation to stay
in front of of those shifts
noting that the consumer demand
for organic is strong um
so the consumer demand is strong and
direct to consumer sales are strong
which i'll talk about a little on the
next slide
um in the organic farmers survey for
2019 new york shows consistent growth
over time in the organic sector ranking
seventh in the country for organic sales
and of the state's 5.4 billion
in produce sales uh six percent of the
total is organic product
more and more farmers are shifting there
there's been a 22 percent increase in
organic farmland
in new york state from 2016 to 2019.
a director can say consumer sales are
growing um
and it's boomed over the last decade and
the pandemic has accelerated that trend
um so the share of farm selling direct
to consumer
in new york state is higher than the
national average
national average is 6.4 in new york
state it's 17
and i think that the
new york state ag markets programs like
uh the new york
state grown and certified have have a
lot to do with that
uh however the data shows it's not just
smaller farms getting into d to c
large farms are also growing in this
sector so
we're looking for technologies that can
support um
distribution and marketing for
direct to consumer
so the the kind of upshot of this and
the report itself will be
live online as of april 12th we'll do
some press work around that that
coincides with the press briefing that
we'll have
announcing the grow new york 30-year
application window being open
and we have produced an executive
summary the report is
being put together as a really beautiful
digital first publication so it's a very
horizontal website um and and i'll be
sure
to share that with greg and don so that
they can get it to any attendees here
once that's live online
putting the final touches on it now but
there's an executive summary piece of it
and here's what it amounts to
we're open for business in this region
and we're particularly interested
in your technology if you're working in
firm robotics anonymous
in automation technologies that support
local supply chains
direct marketing platforms novel crop
protections
biomaterials particularly in the hemp
industry
technologies that can help growers adapt
to and mitigate climate change
investing in diverse and young farmers
and supporting rural economies so
if you are venture capital that wants to
align yourself
with these technologies or you are an
inventor who is working
in these areas you should really turn
your attention to the grow new york
program
so i know we have a heart stop at 1 15
and
um there are at least a couple of
questions so i'm going to
uh to turn to those and if you have
other questions
um go ahead and ask them so one of those
questions was greg warning me about time
uh dunn asked if there's a goal to
expanding the program to all of new york
state
i could see a tremendous upside to doing
that
right now the funding for the program
comes from these regions
and serves these regions these regions
being the finger lakes central new york
and the southern tier
however i get quite a bit of interest
from western new york which is
you know a hair's breath away from the
finger lakes
you know we but and and um and
i could see a benefit to making it a
statewide mandate
um that would be an expansion
of scope that would require an expansion
of budget
and probably different funders for now
we're approaching renewal of this
program as an
upstate revitalization project
continuance so it will continue to serve
those three regions
are there other questions about the
program
one thing i'll note my calendly link is
there
so what i can offer
is if you have a question about
any of the kind of steps in the life
cycle of a company like complex that i
went through where they start off as a
student business
they enter the i-core program and are
kind of
working through nsf to get some
commercialization expertise they
enter a you know a napkin to prototype
program
they stand up their company they pitch
their business they win a chunk of money
they go on and apply for sbir grants
all of that is expertise that my
organization
is here you know missions to share so
get in touch with me and we can talk
about how your research
what the path might look like to get to
get you from research
to commercialization to you know
you know to a seed round or a series a
round for your company and and that
could
happen quite quickly you know that can
that can go from
idea to fully spun out company
in a year um if it's something that that
you want to prioritize
and jen i'll just invite anybody who um
has a question you can either raise your
hand or
put something in the chat box and ask
that
and jen a question for you um so we're
mostly
researchers on the call today or on the
on the seminar today
you know if we have an idea one of us
has an idea and but we don't necessarily
have the
the industry partner the manufacturing
partner
um is that networking something that you
help with
absolutely yeah my organization uh the
center for regional economic advancement
is really well suited to help connect
you
to whatever uh whatever
the kind of co-founder or
or business expertise that that you need
to to get there
would be i will say too
even if you're not in the place where
you're thinking about commercializing
uh your research um i
would be really excited to have
participation
um from from the folks who have checked
this
presentation out in the summit this year
in
in november so um i can see that gary
bergstrom is here hello gary gary was
one of our
um panel moderators last year put
together a really wonderful
panel on emerging crops
would be thrilled to have you
participate if you wanted to have a role
in helping shape some of the content
that we provide
during the program of the summit
please feel free to get in touch with me
about that as well
i don't want to dominate the questions
but i really am curious jen
the one winner that provides
the drone services it wasn't clear to me
what they are actually disseminating on
the field
is it actually honeybees
no it's pollen itself ah
sorry about that yeah and i had had a
video but it it
um it was janky and i felt better to
just keep moving but yeah they they're
using the drones and
and they're pollinating in wayne county
it's apples and israel it's dates in
california they've used it in a couple
of
orange plantations so great
well uh jen really appreciate your time
today
um again anybody who wants to reach out
to jen have a
conversation about your product idea
wants to help
need some help networking and try to
find a way to get your idea to
to market contact jen there's her
calendar invite
link again or you can find her email
she's based here in ithaca
but is out of town today and that's um
that's why she's asking for calendar
appointments
great well please join me in thanking
jen with a round of applause
and um and yeah we can do it
exactly and thank you jen take care
everyone
thanks for the opportunity thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu